hi
i'm mike murashida executive producer at
facebook
resident evil the franchise that changed
the way we think about video games
is still going strong after 25 years
congratulations capcom
on this incredible milestone
now let's rewind for a moment i remember
when resident evil 4
launched in 2005 it was amazing
brilliant nobody had ever seen a game
like it before
and it remains at the pinnacle of the
survival horror genre
in the 16 years since the launch of
residual four the gaming industry has
evolved
and new ways to play have entered the
market and we've been eager to explore
how resident of four could be enhanced
for a modern audience
[Music]
i'm mike verdu vp of content at facebook
reality labs
i'm excited to announce that capcom
oculus studios
and armature studio are partnering to
bring resident evil 4
to quest 2. we're thrilled about this
game we can't wait for you to experience
the world of resident evil
in a new medium it's immersive comes
with a first person perspective
and will bring new richness and depth to
the resident evil 4 experience you know
and love
you'll be able to step inside the game
for the first time
tune in to the oculus gaming showcase
next week
april 21st for more details on resident
evil 4 vr
how we brought this title to this new
medium and you can check out some
additional gameplay footage as well
you can tune in on the oculus facebook
page
or on twitch